FREEZING ANTIFREEZE?
WHAT?
Man: OH, YEAH.
THERE'S A NICE HEALTHY CHUNK
OF ANTIFREEZE RIGHT THERE.
WHAT?! NO!
IT'S NOT POSSIBLE!
Narrator: SO HOW DOES HE FREEZE
ANTIFREEZE?
"ANTIFREEZE" IS THE COMMON NAME
FOR ETHYLENE GLYCOL,
WHICH IS USED TO STOP
CAR RADIATORS FREEZING.
THIS IS BECAUSE IT'S GOT
AN INCREDIBLY LOW
FREEZING POINT
OF MINUS 36 DEGREES FAHRENHEIT
OR MINUS 37.7 DEGREES CELSIUS.
THIS MEANS THAT EVEN THOUGH
IT'S CALLED ANTIFREEZE
YOU CAN STILL FREEZE IT
IF YOU GET IT COLD ENOUGH.
TO FREEZE THE ANTIFREEZE
GRANT USES LIQUID NITROGEN.
NOW, NITROGEN
HAS A BOILING POINT
OF MINUS 321 DEGREES FAHRENHEIT.
THAT'S MINUS 196 DEGREES
CELSIUS.
THAT MAKES IT A LOT, LOT
LOTS COLDER
THAN THE FREEZING POINT
OF THE ANTIFREEZE.
THE ANTIFREEZE
AND THE NITROGEN
WANT TO REACH WHAT'S CALLED
THERMAL EQUILIBRIUM.
WHEN HE PUTS THE RELATIVELY
WARMER ROOM-TEMPERATURE
ANTIFREEZE
INTO THE MUCH COLDER
LIQUID NITROGEN
THEY BOTH WANT
TO REACH THE SAME TEMPERATURE.
THE LIQUID NITROGEN
WILL DO THIS BY HEATING UP,
WHICH IS WHY WE SEE IT BOILING,
WHILE THE ANTIFREEZE IS GONNA
LOSE SOME OF THAT HEAT,
AND THIS IS WHY IT FREEZES.
Linsell: BECAUSE
THE LIQUID NITROGEN IS SO COLD
IT TAKES VIRTUALLY NO TIME
FOR THE HEAT
TO LEAVE THE ANTIFREEZE
BRINGING IT BELOW
IT'S FREEZING TEMPERATURE,
TURNING IT INTO A SOLID.
Man: OH, YEAH.
THERE'S A NICE HEALTHY CHUNK
OF ANTIFREEZE RIGHT THERE.
ANTIFREEZE
IS INCREDIBLY POISONOUS,
AND LIQUID NITROGEN
IS DANGEROUSLY COLD.
SO DEFINITELY DO NOT
TRY THIS AT HOME.
♪♪